for the first time in my life had to
essentially die to wake up demi lovato
says it was her near fatal overdose
in 2018 that caused her to wake up
the doctors
told me that i had uh five to ten
minutes
and before like if no one had found me
then i wouldn't be here
and
i'm grateful that i'm sitting here today
yeah in a new interview with cbs sunday
morning which will air
in full on sunday journalist tracy smith
notes that she previously spoke with the
28 year old singer in 2016
where they had a similar conversation
about addiction
i was probably 24 when we did the
interview
so we're doing this interview i'm in
recovery from a bunch of things
and i
i've been sober for however many years
but i'm still miserable
for the first time in my life had to
essentially die to wake up demi's highly
anticipated docu-series demi lovato
dancing with the devil
premiered at south by southwest earlier
this week and in it
the former child star reveals some
shocking details about her overdose
and her life today i had three strokes
i had a heart attack my doctors said
that i had
five to ten more minutes one surprising
revelation
demi admits she's no longer sober in the
wake of the overdose
the big reveal at the end is that demi
is not sober
is that she is drinking and smoking weed
in moderation
um how did you feel
ending with that are you worried about
how her fans might take it
we talked about it and in the
documentary uh
we were very careful to not preach any
uh one-size-fits-all solution e.t sat
down with director
michael d ratner and he opened up about
demi's approach to recovery
she's still figuring out what works for
her um
this is her truth and she's not saying
it's perfect she's saying that she's
figuring it out so uh it was important
to me and to us
and and and i felt the responsibility
also to include other opinions
of people that don't feel like the path
she's taking is the right one
and again we're also saying that the
rest is unwritten i mean there's a
very powerful moment when she says you
know you're not going to go and open up
the article and see me as the headline
in a negative way again
um but i say that with humility and
knowing how
that it's a powerful disease so i do
anticipate
a conversation to start and i hope that
it ultimately helps people quite frankly
and he said demi is committed to working
on herself
she says i am a work in progress i
understand
what a serious disease addiction is i
understand that i am battling
x y and z i mean you'll see the film but
she ultimately is saying
i am working on things every single day
i've put systems in place because i am a
flawed person
here's where i am today and i'm i'm here
to tell you my journey so
um i think she's really proud of the
work i really believe that uh today
demi is is working on herself so much
and she's in the best place she's been
um but again she is she's not fixed
you